>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IF YOU WERE ON SOCIAL MEDIA
OVER THE WEEKEND YOU
PROBABLY SAW THIS VIDEO.
IT WAS SHOT FRIDAY AFTERNOON
ON THE STEPS OF THE LINCOLN
MEMORIAL IT SEEMED TO SHOW A
GROUP OF TEENAGE BOYS
TAUNTING AN ELDERLY AMERICAN
INDIAN MAN WHO WAS HOLDING A
DRUM.
THE YOUNG MEN HAD COME TO
WASHINGTON FROM A CATHOLIC
SCHOOL IN KENTUCKY TO
DEMONSTRATE IN THE MARCH FOR
LIFE.
SOME OF THEM WORE MAKE
AMERICA GREAT AGAIN HATS.
THEY SEEM MENACING.
WITHIN HOURS THE VIDEO IS
BEING REPLAYED BY VIRTUALLY
EVERY NEWS OUTLET IN
AMERICA.
HERE'S WHAT YOU MAY HAVE
SEEN.
♪
[CHANTING]
>> Tucker: THE AMERICAN
INDIAN MAN WITH THE DRUM YOU
JUST SAW IS CALLED NATHAN
PHILLIPS.
AND HE DESCRIBED THE YOUNG
MEN HE ENCOUNTERED, THE ONES
IN THE HATS AS AGGRESSIVE
AND THREATENING.
ESSENTIALLY SHOCK TROOPS FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
WATCH.
>> HEARD THEM SAYING BUILD
THAT WALL.
BUILD THAT WALL.
THIS IS INDIGENOUS LANDS.
NOT SUPPOSED TO HAVE A WALL
HERE.
NEVER DID.
>> Tucker: IT'S HARD TO
REMEMBER THE LAST TIME THE
GREAT AMERICAN PEOPLE
MACHINE PRODUCED A CLEARER
CONTRAST BETWEEN GOOD AND
EVIL.
IT WAS ESSENTIALLY AN ENTIRE
MORALITY PLAY SHRUNK DOWN TO
FOUR MINUTES FOR FACEBOOK.
ON THE ONE SIDE YOU HAD A
NOBLE TRIBAL ELDER WEATHER
BEATEN CALM.
YOU CAN IMAGINE A SINGLETARY
SLIDING DOWN HIS CHEEK AT
THE SENSELESSNESS OF IT ALL.
AND ON THE OTHER SIDE
HEEDLESS YOUNGS MEN FROM THE
SOUTH DRUNK ON RACISM AND
WHITE PRIVILEGE.
THE IRONY WAS OVERWHELMING.
THE INDIGENOUS MAN'S LAND
STOLEN BY THE ANCESTORS OF
THESE BOYS IN MAGA HATS AND
DARE TO LECTURE HIM ABOUT
WALLS WHO LOOK VERY MUCH
LIKE HIM OUT OF WHAT THEY
WERE CALLING OUT OF THEIR
COUNTRY.
IT WAS INFURIATING TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE.
AT THE SAME TIME, WAS ALSO
STRANGELY COMFORTING TO
THOSE WHO WATCHED IT FROM
BROOKLYN AND L.A.
THE PEOPLE WHO RUN THIS
COUNTRY HAVE LONG SUSPECTED
THAT MIDDLE AMERICA IS A
HIVE OF NATIVIST BIGOTRY AND
NOW THEY HAD PROOF OF THAT.
A CAUSE FOR A CELEBRATION OF
OUTRAGE A BECAUSE NOTHING
QUITE AS SATISFYING AS
HAVING YOUR OWN BIASES
CONFIRMED.
BUT DID THE VIDEO REALLY
DESCRIBE WHAT HAPPENED?
THAT SHOULD HAVE BEEN THE
FIRST QUESTION THAT JIRNLSES
JOURNALISTS ASKED.
CHECKING FACTS IS WHAT
JOURNALISTS ARE PAID TO DO.
FIRST LINE OF THE JOB
DESCRIPTION.
YET, AMAYSINGLY.
ALMOST NOBLE IN THE AMERICAN
MEDIA DID THAT.
AND THAT'S A SHAME BECAUSE
THERE WAS A LOT TO CHECK.
THE FULL VIDEO OF WHAT
HAPPENED ON FRIDAY IN
WASHINGTON IS WELL OVER AN
HOUR LONG.
THE FOUR MINUTES THAT MADE
TWITTER DON'T TELL THE STORY
BUT, INSTEAD, DISTORT THE
STORY.
A LONGER LOOK SHOWS THAT THE
BOYS FROM COVINGTON CATHOLIC
IN KENTUCKY WERE NOT A
ROVING MOB LOOKING FOR A
FIGHT.
THEY WERE, IN FACT, AND IT
SHOWS IT ON THE TAPE
STANDING IN PLACE WAITING TO
BE PICKED UP BY A BUS.
AS THEY WAITED THERE.
MEMBERS OF A GROUP CALLED
THE BLACK HEBREW ISRAELITES
BLACK SUPREMACIST
ORGANIZATION BEGAN TAUNTING
THEM WITH RACIAL EPITAPHS
AND THEN NATHAN PHILLIPS,
THE NOW FAMOUS INDIAN
ACTIVIST APPROACHED THEM
POUNDING ON HIS DRUM.
THE FOOTAGE SEEMS TO SUGGEST
THE BOYS WERE UNSURE WHETHER
PHILLIPS WAS HOSTILE OR
TAKING THEIR SIDE AGAINST
THE BLACK HEBREW ISRAELITES.
BUT, IN ANY CASE, THERE IS
NO EVIDENCE AT ALL THAT
ANYBODY SAID BUILD A WALL.
HERE'S A SELECTION OF WHAT
DIDN'T MAKE SOCIAL MEDIA.
[SHOUTING]
>> Tucker: SO WHAT REALLY
HAPPENED ON FRIDAY?
YOU CAN WATCH FOR YOURSELF
AND DECIDE.
THERE IS PLENTY OF VIDEO OUT
THERE OF IT.
AND SOME OF IT IS
FASCINATING AND REVEALING.
WHAT WE KNOW FOR CERTAIN AT
THIS POINT IS THAT OUR
CULTURAL LEADERS ARE IN
EFFECT BIGOTS.
THEY UNDERSTAND THE REALITY
ON THE BASIS OF STEREOTYPES.
WHEN THE FACTS DON'T CONFORM
TO WHAT THEY THINK THEY
KNOW, THEY IGNORE THE FAX.
THEY SEE THIS COUNTRY NOT A
GROUP OF PEOPLE OR OF
CITIZENS BUT AS A COLLECTION
OF GROUPS AND SOME OF THOSE
GROUPS THEY'RE CONVINCED ARE
MORALLY INTERIOR TO OTHER
GROUPS.
THEY KNOW THAT'S TRUE THEY
SAY IT OUT LOUD.
AND THAT BELIEF SHAPES
ALMOST ALL OF THEIR
PERCEPTIONS OF THE WORLD.
IT'S NOT SURPRISING THEN
THAT WHEN A GROUP OF
PRO-LIFE CATHOLIC KIDS WHO
LOOK LIKE LACROSSE PLAYERS
AND LIVE IN KENTUCKY ARE
ACCUSED OF WRONGDOING THE
MEDIA DON'T STAND FOR A
MOMENT WITHOUT CASTING
JUDGMENT.
SUGGESTED THE BOYS NEED TO
BE EXPELLED FROM SCHOOL.
AMY NAVARRO CALLED THE BOYS
RACIST AND ASS WIPES AND
WENT AFTER TEACHERS AND
PARENTS.
OTHERS CALL FOR VIOLENCE
AGAINST THEM.
CNN LEGAL ANALYST SUGGESTED
ONE OF THE BOYS SHOULD BE,
QUOTE:  PUNCHED IN THE FACE.
FORMER CNN CONTRIBUTOR
AGREED.
ASKED ON TWITTER HAVE YOU
EVER SEEN A MORE PUNCHABLE
FACE THAN THIS KID'S.
KATHY GRIFFIN SEEMED TO
ENCOURAGE A MOB TO RISE UP
AND HURT THESE BOYS.
NAME THESE KIDS.
I WANT NAMES.
SHAME THEM IF YOU THINK
THESE FERS WOULDN'T DOCKS
NEW A HEART BEAT.
NAMES PLEASE AND STORIES
FROM PEOPLE WHO CAN IDENTIFY
THEM AND VOUCH FOR THEIR
IDENTITY.
THANK YOU.
HOLLYWOOD FILM PRODUCER JACK
MORSI WANTED THE BOYS
KILLED
MAGA KIDS GO SCREAMING HEAD
FIRST INTO
HARST INTO
HATST INTO
HATS FINTO
HATS FIRTO
HATS FIRST INTO THE WOOD
CHIPPER.
IN CASE ANYONE WANTED TO GET
STARTED ON PROJECT.
TWITTER WHICH CLAIMS TO HAVE
A POLICY AGAINST VIOLENCE
STOOD BY SILENTLY AS THIS
ALL HAPPENED.
IN CASE YOU THINK.
THE ABUSE WAS BIPARTISAN.
IT WASN'T JUST LEFT VS.
RIGHT.
IT WAS THE PEOPLE IN POWER
ATTACKING THOSE BELOW THEM.
AS A GROUP.
PLENTY OF REPUBLICANS IN
WASHINGTON WERE HAPPY TO
SAVAGE THE COVINGTON KIDS
PROBABLY TO INOCULATE
THEMSELVES FROM CHARGES OF
IMPROPER THOUGHT.
BILL KRISTOL ASKED HIS
TWITTER FOLLOWERS TO
CONSIDER THE CONTRAST
BETWEEN THE CALM DIGNITY AND
QUIET STRENGTH PLAINTIFF
PHILLIPS AND THE BEHAVIOR OF
MAGA BRATS WHO HAVE ABSORBED
THE SPIRIT OF TRUMPISM.
AND THEN WHEN THE ACTUAL
FACTS EMERGED KRISTOL
QUIETLY DELETED HIS TWEET.
HE NEVER APOLOGIZED OF
COURSE.
HE HASN'T APOLOGIZED FOR THE
IRAQ WAR EITHER.
NO NEED PEOPLE KEEP GIVING
HIM MONEY.
THE COVINGTON STUDENTS MIGHT
AS WELL HAVE SPIT ON THE
CROSS THAT STORY HAS SENSE
BEEN PULLED, TOO.
THE AUTHOR ADMITTED HE NEVER
EVEN BOTHERED TO WATCH ALL
OF THE VIDEOS.
HE KNEW WHAT HE KNEW AND
THAT WAS ENOUGH.
WHAT'S SO INTERESTING ABOUT
THE COVERAGE OF FRIDAY'S
VIDEOS IS HOW MUCH OF IT
MENTIONED SOMETHING CALLED
PRIVILEGE.
ALEX CONTROLLED SUBSTANCE AN
EDITOR WROTE THIS FROM EMPTY
SCHOOL THROUGH COLLEGE I
WENT TO SCHOOL WITH SHELTER
TERRED MIDDLE CLASS WHITE
BOYS WHO COULD DEVASTATE
WITH A SMIRK.
A FACIAL GESTURE THAT
WEAPONIZED THEIR PRIVILEGE.
INFURIATINGLY YOU CAN'T
FIGHT THAT F'ING SMIRK WITH
A PUNCH OR WORDS.
WE SAW THAT AS TRUMP SMIRKED
HIS WAY THROUGH THE ELECTION
AND SEE IT AS THAT BOY'S
FAMILY AND SCHOOLS PROTECT
HIM
IIM
IHATE THAT SMIRK IT SAYS I'M
RICHER, I'M WHITE AND I'M A
GUY:  THESE ARE HIGH SCHOOL
KIDS FROM KENTUCKY.
DO THEY REALLY HAVE MORE
PRIVILEGE AN ALEX CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE FROM GIZ MOTO?
PROBABLY NOT.
IN FACT PROBABLY MUCH LESS.
FAR LESS PRIVILEGED IN FACT
THAN EVERYONE WHO HAS CALLED
FOR THEM TO BE DESTROYED ON
THE BASIS THEY HAVE TOO MUCH
PRIVILEGE.
CONSIDER KARA SWISHER AN
OPINION COLUMNIST FOR THE
"NEW YORK TIMES."
SWISHER WENT TO DAY SCHOOL
AND GEORGETOWN AND GRADUATE
DEGREE AT COLUMBIA.
RICH AND FAMOUS BY
BILLIONAIRE TECH CEO HAND
MAIDEN.
NOBODY CONSIDERS HER VERY
TALENTED AND SOMEWHAT HIGHLY
INFLUENTIAL IN OUR SOCIETY.
SHE MORE PRIVILEGED THAN THE
BOYS OF COVINGTON CATHOLIC
AT KENTUCKY?
OF COURSE SHE IS.
MAYBE THAT'S WHY SHE FEELS
THE NEED TO CALL THEM NAZIS
WHICH SHE DID REPEATEDLY.
WHAT'S ACTUALLY GOING ON
HERE?
WELL, IT'S NOT REALLY ABOUT
RACE.
IN FACT, MOST OF THE STORIES
ABOUT RACE AREN'T REALLY
ABOUT RACE THIS SO NO
DIFFERENT.
THIS IS ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN
FOX ALL
POX ALL
POWEALL
POWERLL
POWER PROTECTING THEIR POWER
AND DESTROYING THOSE AND
MOCKING THOSE WEAKER THAN
THEY ARE.
THE REASON SIMPLE THE
LEADERS HAVE NOT IMPROVED
THE LIVES OF MOST PEOPLE IN
AMERICA.
THEY CAN'T ADMIT THAT
BECAUSE IT WAS DISCREDIT
THEM.
INSTEAD THEY ATTACK THE VERY
PEOPLE THEY HAVE FAILED.
THE PROBLEM THEY WILL TELL
US WITH KENTUCKY ISN'T THAT
THE POLICIES HAVE HURT THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE IT'S
THAT THE PEOPLE WHO LIVE
THERE ARE IMMORAL BECAUSE
THEY ARE BIGOTS.
THEY DESERVE THEIR POVERTY
AND THEIR OPIOID ADDICTION.
THEY DESERVE TO DIE YOUNG.
THAT'S WHAT OUR LEADERS TELL
THEMSELVES.